ça vous étiez l'avocate des victimes
vous avez déposé 30 plaintes contre x à
l'encontre du groupe korian et le groupe
c le record concurrents d'orpea quelles
sont ces accusations aujourd'hui alors
il ya plusieurs chefs d'accusation
notamment homicide involontaire mais
c'est pas pour tous les dossiers non
assistance à personne en danger et mise
en danger de la vie d'autrui pour les
principaux donc ce sont chaque dossier
bien sûr et singulier mais ce sont des
faits à mon sens d'une extrême gravité
même si pour l'instant korian est
présumé innocent avec ce sera bien sûr à
la justice d'en décider alors pourquoi
ce qu'une plainte contre x et pas contre
korian directement sacré pas compris
alors parce que quand on en avait parlé
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure en fait quand
vous regardez dans infogreffe qui est là
où on peut voir les sociétés pour korian
il ya souvent des sociétés écrans c'est
à dire par exemple on signe avec medica
avec une autre société et donc pour
englober plus de monde entre guillemets
je les ai mis contre personne non
dénommée mais m une autre société tout à
fait légal n'y a pas de difficultés là
dessus alors albert comme j'ai dit vous
avez travaillé pendant 15 ans pour le
groupe korian vous avez été chef de
cuisine vous êtes devenu ensuite
permanent syndical à temps plein
qu'est-ce que vous avez constaté au fil
des ans on chez korian mais c'est une
société qui est là pour faire uniquement
du profit de la rentabilité c'est tout
le reste est secondaire se dire qu'on
est con fait de l'empathie quand on
s'occupe des personnes âgées ce sont les
salariés qui s'occupent des personnes
jose e sur le terrain bien sûr que oui
vous prenez une aide soignante elle
entre 7 et 10 minutes le matin pour
faire une toilette quand je prends ma
douche matin le coup de rasoir un coup
de brosse à dents bon au niveau
shampoing jeux pas trop problème touche
j'en ai pour à 15 20 minutes cela une
personne âgée qui est importante qui est
sûr en liquette allongé il faut
l'apprendre faut la tourner il ya des
gestes techniques à faire et des gestes
et mini quoi faire c'est hyper compliqué
entre 7 et 10 minutes tout ça pour faire
de la rentabilité c'est une salariée une
aide soignante pour dix résidents or
vous donner des exemples de la toile est
ce que vous avez d'autres exemples à
nous donner sur le quotidien en tant que
résidents qu'aux rayons sur le quotidien
on en parlait avec avec guillaume une
personne âgée sur une journée de 24
heures elle a deux heures et quelques de
présence humaine à côté d'elle
thierry que ça déjà c'est un constat
c'est un constat qui est incroyable
la nuit vous avez 2 à 3 personnes dans
souvent s'il n'y a pas des ja pas
d'infirmières dans les maisons de
retraite 1 la nuit ya pas de problème
il ya deux aides soignantes par exemple
à partir de senlis 2 3 % résident à 410
notes et vont se reposer avant de manger
un morceau fumer une cigarette il n'y a
plus que deux personnes qui errent dans
les étages et dont il ya il faut savoir
aussi que les les personnes âgées ils
ont une difficulté
entre le jour entre la nuit on a des
personnes qui ont des pathologies
particulières notamment alzheimer qui
peuvent déambuler dans les couloirs si
vous êtes le deuxième étage quelle
personne de 1 me au 4ème étage on fait
comment on peut pas le savoir alors donc
elle n'arrête pas de courir c'est c'est
totalement c'est un boulot de fou quoi
c'est un signal des exemples comme ça
ils sont à trois puisque c'est vrai que
trois personnes pour 100 résidents dans
la nuit c'est vrai qu'on m'a dit on sait
que les personnes âgées à se réveille
souvent de rennes où il peut y avoir des
accidents on peut avoir des chutes
est-ce que vous avez déjà vu vous un
truc et enfin où vous a raconté un truc
qui s'est passé une personne âgée qui
est resté peut-être par terre toute la
nuit parce qu'il est personne je sais
pas ce qu'on entend des choses
incroyables
oui au niveau des choses incroyables
malheureusement ça fait quand même des
années qu'on apprend par les articles de
presse régionaux des des choses un peu
oui horrible j'ai pas d'autres mots
c'est horrible parce qu'effectivement il
ya des choses où on peut avoir des
homicides entre résidents sous manque de
surveillance non
oui donc ça effectivement c'est des
choses qu'on connaît depuis assez
longtemps quand même malheureusement
dans le secteur on le dénonce nous à la
cgt depuis très longtemps
au niveau du groupe orpea on vient de
voir qu effectivement au delà d'un
problème effectivement de maltraitance
on se rend compte qu'il y ait un système
mafieux mais là il est très clair c'est
poser aujourd'hui on vient d'avoir
perquisition sur le groupe perquisitions
sur les directions régionales donc
effectivement on se rend compte que
malheureusement dans ce secteur
d'activité les opérateurs sont pas aussi
bienveillant qu'ils le font croire je
maintiens à dire à tout le monde quand
même quand vous regardez les cinq plus
gros opérateur dans les épaves lucrative
vous regardez les fondateurs de ces
groupes ils font tous partie des 500
plus grosses fortunes de france
je vous parle d'un secteur qui a entre
25 et 30 ans maximum
je vous parle d'un secteur qui est
appuyée sur de l'argent public
donc là on a vraiment une très fin il y
a un problème au delà même effectivement
de ceux des scandales qui arrivait avec
puisqu'on peut voir effectivement les
familles les salariés aussi qu'ils sont
froides de ce système là ne l'oublions
pas alors j'ai dit on vous qu'est ce que
vous avez vu est ce que vous étiez
pendant 18 ans vous avez été licencié
après 18 ans de service en tant que chef
cuisiner est-ce que vous pouvez nous
raconter le quotidien de ces personnes
qui sont qui sont résidents là bas de
même au niveau de la nourriture et mot
niveau voilà comment ça se passe au
niveau des repas est-ce que vous avez vu
parce qu'on a on dans le livre de victor
on a vu plein de choses est-ce que vous
pouvez nozick nous aiguiller nous
éclairer alors le côté le plus le plus
marquant pour tout le monde en tout cas
c'est effectivement le coût journalier
que nous avons dans ces établissements
pour nourrir les résidents
vous korian orpea qu'on a ça coûte et on
voit sa cote est pour un résident par
exemple c'est par jour vous prenez 4
euros 50 pour faire le petit déjeuner
le repas de midi
le 4 heures et le repas du soir donc ça
coûte à orpéa 85 en essayant encore et
encore un bonus c'est à peu près tout de
même les mêmes 4,050 pas résidents et
combien paient un résident par mois et
alors on va prendre on va prendre un
mois on va prendre des moyens existants
on va prendre des moyennes sur les
établissements orpea korian on est entre
3 et 4000 euros par mois sachant que
vous avez des établissements en fonction
de où vous êtes géographiquement située
la région parisienne est une région
effectivement dans ce haut niveau
population et avec un haut niveau
logement et ben oui des loyers très cher
donc vous avez là effectivement des
loyers qu'il tourne plus aux alentours
de 7000 euros je parle de loyer parce
qu'effectivement nos entreprises euh
vous font croire qu'effectivement c'est
des sociétés de santé non non ce sont
des foncières exactement la société
orpea à un chiffre d'affaires de à peu
près pour 2021 2,4 milliards et des 4
milliards 2 par contre vous regardez ils
ont un patrimoine immobilier de huit
milliards c'est incroyable et pour
ajouter deux sur l'argent public ce qui
est important le salaire des soignants
est financé à hauteur de 60 % de la
masse salariale par la sécurité sociale
quand même
votre commerçant de quartier il a pas 60
% 4 l'état lui verse pour payer ses
salaires et ses salaires 1
les dispositifs médicaux qui sont payés
aussi avec que de l'argent public et
guillaume départementale donc positif
médicaux pour que tout le monde
comprenne bien ce sont les protections
les couches vous voyez dans le livre de
victor castanet
que on a des rétrocommissions alors ils
appellent ça des rfa des rétro
commissions rétrocommissions sur des
dispositifs médicaux payés avec de
l'argent public je ne sais pas comment
vous appelez ça vous mais moi j'appelle
ça du vol maric nature
c'est incroyable s'est hissée c'est fou
c'est fou et quand vous dites no 4 euros
50 donc résidents coûte 4 euros 50 par
jour en coûts matières repas donc vont
en découdre de profits ça veut dire
qu'ils coûtent à regarder vous avec 4
euros 50 écrit vous êtes capable de
pouvoir manger ne paul midy je suis à
paris donc si ça veut dire quoi c'est à
dire que les rations de son poisson à la
qualité alors
cessé global c'est global il faut
commencer info mesurer aussi comment ces
gens là qu'on soit leur business des
économies d'échelle on est on apprend le
groupe orpea 227 établissements ils ont
centralisé les repas donc il a aussi
l'aberration rôle c'est à dire qu on
oublie totalement les goûts dans les
régions c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui chez
leur père à tous non damman je vous dis
n'importe dans les 227 été licencié le
même mois par la même chose attaquants
donc au niveau des achats vous comprenez
bien que quand vous faites du
bourguignon l'addition à 50 grammes de
bourguillon l'htc des tonnes d après
vous apprenez dans les scandales qui
viennent d'être révélés que orpea
démonter une centrale d'achat en suisse
pour permettre effectivement de
détourner de l'argent via sa son
calvaire 1 en francs suisses ouais c'est
fou c'est incroyable dans le serré que
cette histoire est folle et donc alors
50 vous dit c'est quoi ces des produits
de mauvaise qualité on va se servir la
mauvaise qualité
c'est très subjectif d'accord là moi ou
ça me pose problème alors là pour le
coup effectivement on va voir avec le
rapport igas igf qui sont tombés où il
ya eu des mises en doute sur
effectivement le rap enfin l'apport
nutritionnel
effectifs de ces repas c'est à dire que
nous à la cgt on a des doutes sur
effectivement le rationnement entre
guillemets fait en tout cas les
grammages qui nous sont imposées en tant
que chef de cuisine je vous donne un
exemple je vous donne un exemple le
c'est très frappant pour moi parce que
quand vous posez dans une assiette le
rôti de veau le soir dans nos
établissements c'était 40 g je vous
demande à tous de peser 40 g et le pot
mettre dans une assiette et de vous
rendre compte de ce que ça représente
pour manger le soir en sachant qu'en
plus haut niveau de l'amplitude horaire
au niveau de la prise de repas pour nous
résidons est pratiquement dans toutes
les étapes ça peut préparer 18h30 19h
quand tout va bien mais c'est plus 18h30
et c'est jusqu'au lendemain 7 heures
d'accord donc quand vous avez 40 g de
protéines
dans le corps pro 13 heures non jusqu'à
ce qu'on a dans un premier temps un
autre ayant fait alors là aussi on a des
chiffres il ya des chiffres le qu'il le
démontre on estime à peu près à 70% de
taux de dénutri dont les établissements
quoi c'est incroyable et donc il est
arrivé voilà qui est des quais des
personnes là qui se disent voilà on est
on qui se lève la nuit qui disent qu'on
a on a envie de on est on a faim on est
enquis qui recoupe personnes qui c'est
qui qui cherchent un brouilleur la nuit
est prévu le cola sur un petit gâteau au
yaourt osséja messac alsac inde afin
mais au moins c'est ce que je dis est au
delà de ça c'est encore une fois de plus
les salariés qui prennent le dessus
parce que nos cuisiniers en ehpad y sont
bons c'est bien sûr la raison à l'école
ils ont travaillé dans des dents du
privé où ils ont travaillé dans des
restaurants et il arrive à a compensé
par la qualité de leur travail un petit
peu là la qualité de ces quand vous
disiez c'est pas de mauvaise qualité
qu'on a mais par exemple la vache de la
vache allemands 2
pour faire de boeuf bourguignon vous
savez que les allemands sont beaucoup
donné et quand les vaches ne font plus
de lait on les tue c'est cet avc vaches
l' enlèvement pour la collectivité enfin
moi j'ai travaillé dans ce secteur là
dedans juste de quoi je parle donc en
bouche de la vache de la vache allemande
qui a qu'il ya deux ans trois ans quatre
ans ou dix ans et dont car effectivement
il faut il faut être vraiment j'ai
toujours dit que nos cuisiniers étaient
des magiciens on est tous les deux
cuisiniers dans ses seins des magiciens
parce qu'elle arrive à faire du bon de
la qualité avec des produits qui sont
très difficiles à travailler alors vous
êtes restés tous les deux si longtemps
15 ans et 18 ans
c'est la question que j'ai envie de
poser c'est pourquoi vous êtes resté
bien sûr vous êtes resté aussi longtemps
là parce que vous quand vous rendez vous
êtes voilà il est chez vous soit vous
disiez franchement c'est des conditions
inacceptables et gérance et à bouger
josette où les deux déléguées syndicales
voilà si j'étais donc forcément vous
dédié où on est on veut essayer de faire
bouger bouger les jouets ce qui m'a fait
rester dans le groupe enfin je pensais
albert ça va être à peu près la même
chose c'est qu'effectivement mon
engagement syndical qui me fait rester
dans le groupe d'accord c'est que très
très tôt il a fallu je me suis rendu
compte qu'effectivement il y avait des
problèmes problématique est en tout cas
de ce qu'on me demandait de faire
il y avait des choses qui n'allaient pas
et donc à partir du moment où dans ces
groupes là vous commencez à faire
remonter auprès de votre hiérarchie en
disant non mais attendez ce que vous ne
peut être faire c'est pas possible on
n'y arrive pas il ya des problèmes on se
rend compte qu'on est au niveau en tout
cas de ce qui devrait être rendu ça va
pas ça passe pas et là vous commencez à
rentrer en conflit avec votre hiérarchie
est donc très très vite il met cette
femme en tout cas pour moi mais je pense
que pour albert c'est la même chose il
me semblait nécessaire d'aller en tout
cas me syndiquer et en plus très très
vite après m'engager au niveau syndical
l'entreprise moi et moi je moi je suis
entrée en maison de retraite pour deux
raisons tout à fait personnelles j'avais
matin tu es ma mère qui est en maison de
retraite j'avais besoin de vois là je ne
pouvais pas participer à la vie de ma
mère et de ma tendre dont je vais
participer à la vie d'autres personnes
j'ai perdu beaucoup d'argent a travaillé
dans des restaurants j'ai perdu beaucoup
d'argent mais peu importe je m'en
foutais je les fais parce que j'avais
vraiment envie de le faire et comme
guillaume à un moment donné quand on a
vu les conditions de travail quand on a
vu ce que l'on veut faire moi combien de
fois j'ai dit dans des réunions
nationales de d'accord jeudi mais moi je
fais plus mon métier c'est plus mon
métier si j'avais su quand j'ai fait mon
école hôtelière quand j'avais 17 18 ans
que je vais faire ce métier là j'aurais
pas fait d'école tenir ça c'est clair et
net je suis pas cuisinier était déçu en
plus vous vous étiez est complètement
déçus parce que vous avez laissé tomber
un travail dans lequel vous gagnez bien
votre type pour parce que je m'éclate et
faisait véritablement de la cuisine est
là et là on se retrouve à faire manger
des gens avec des moyens limités c'est
pas notre métier mais ce que je vous dis
en tant que cuisinier les aides
soignantes les infirmières vous le
disent aussi elles sont allées à l'école
elles aussi elles ont fait des études et
10 mai à l'école on nous apprend pas à
faire ça je me reconnais pas dans le
métier d'aide-soignante ou dans le
métier d'infirmier j'ai une question à
poser est ce que les salaires sont plus
élevés que dans des groupes voilà
hospitalier public c'est simple mais
alors là aussi pour le coup ça c'est des
chiffres du ministère fin de l'adresse
de ses quais fectivement dans votre
secteur on a notre branche
professionnelle sur le salaire médian on
a 400 euros d'écart d'accord en plus
quoi vous êtes autant en dessous en
dessous oui en deux autres manches trois
idées sont en revanche d'accord et aussi
vous prenez la branche l'acte i et qui
est la plus rémunérée rémunératrices il
ya mille euros d'écart d'accord pour
diplôme équivalent donc effectivement
contrôlé une infirmière un bac + 3 quand
on regarde la pénurie d'infirmières mais
c'est face à va pas s'arrêter
malheureusement ça celle où ça ne va pas
s'arrêter aujourd'hui aujourd'hui juste
guillaume et et albert et d'ailleurs ça
est-ce qu'on voit
des inscriptions de moins en moins
nombreux dans ces groupes après tout
c'est ce qu'on a entendu ou est-ce que
c'est toujours aussi
aussi prisée aussi a toujours autant de
monde ça n'a pas forcément d'autres
solutions c'est ça risque est terrible
c'est ça en fait où est ce qu'on peut
enfin la question c'est que fait-on pas
ce que dira on ne peut pas se passer à
mon sens des ehpad privé la question
c'est quelles solutions on peut offrir
donc c'est toujours plus là toujours
plein c'est ici on l on a un manque de
on avait on a un manque de place on a un
manque de places en france on à 7500
epad le secteur lucratif en représente à
peu près 25% eux
on estime qu il nous en faudrait au
moins 2000 de plus avec ce qui va
arriver à la population vieillissante
nous à la cgt on estime qu'ils me
manquent deux cent mille professionnels
dans ces ehpad vous imaginez chantier là
que sont en train de vous et de vous
décrire on voit bien qu effectivement
les gouvernements successifs en plus
nous annonce a fait le troisième avec
nous allons enfin le nouveau en tête
voir s'il va nous proposer mais enfin en
tout cas ça fait 15 ans qu'on nous
appelle on nous annonce un plan grand
âge y'a rien qui se passe rien qui se
passe les scandales se poursuivent les
uns derrière les autres on arrive avec
orpea je pense que là quand même il va
falloir faire quelque chose car ils ont
ouvert des enquêtes pour les plainte que
j'ai déposée au parquet de nanterre
voilà parce que alors il risque quoi les
condamnations mais pour l'instant j'ai
la banane à sion je peux vraiment rien
c'est là-dessus homero au pire c'est
quoi ils vont avoir des gosses
condamnation financière à beaujeu
représente ne sont pas animés par une
volonté financière non mais mais qui
sait pas ce qu'on va pas fermer pas si
bassement établissements qui ont été
fermés et des images qui ne masque pas
la butte la justice tranchera mais la
question c'est que fait-on pour la suite
et là où je j'ajouterai quelque chose
c'est que les gens quand ils payent 4000
euros ils s'attendent à un très bon ça
bien c'est
vrai mais quand un match compliqué que
c'était pas terrible on se dit c'est le
public quand on met quatre mille euros
les personnes j'ai des personnes qui se
sont endettés et qui sont en commission
de surendettement pour avoir pêché orpea
dont qui ont fait de réels sacrifices
pour leur part en disant je vais offrir
le meilleur c'est ça oui et elles auront
parle d'orpea on parle de korian mais
malheureusement il y en a beaucoup et là
j'ai le témoignage d'un ami qui m'écrit
qui me dit ma mois dans une maison de
retraite je pense à tous les gens qui se
disent mais comment on va faire quoi oui
c'est un autre établissement je vais pas
citer gros scandale la rsa fermer cet
établissement pendant six mois ma maman
est tombé dans un escalier avec son
fauteuil roulant pour manque de
barrières et d'attention fracture de la
mâchoire hématome de l'épaule nous
sommes dans la peine ma soeur ne veut
plus la remettre dans l'ehpad elle l'a
pris chez elle ce sont des roublards et
le personnel n'en peut plus c'est un
témoignage de jean reçoit des plaintes
nous on sait
ce qui est terrible c'est
qu'effectivement le constat là je vous
le redis c'est pas aujourd'hui ça fait
pas cinq mois depuis que le livre de
l'état aurait sens bien
en 2018 y avait déjà eu des mouvements
dans les ehpad on avait déjà renoncé on
a eu la grève de foudre en 117 jours de
grève là aussi il va falloir que ça soit
la société qui sont en par là il ya un
problème sociétal c'est qu'est ce qu'on
fait de nos anciens et comment on en
prend en charge on est en 2022 en france
je suis désolé de vous le dire mais on
n'est pas digne on n'est pas digne
les pays nordiques
de les pays nordiques dépenses entre 4
et 5% de leur pib produit intérieur brut
chien pour la prise en charge la
dépendance un enfant soit à 0,5 et
veyran aurait annoncé qu' effectivement
si on faisait un pressoir il passerait à
1,5 bon il plus là donc oui ça va ça va
pas le faire nous on n'est pas contre
système epad le système ehpad il pas
pire que qu'un autre c'est comment sont
gérées n'en est pas content bien sûr ça
et puis donner 500 il est très clair
aussi qu'il est inconcevable que dans la
santé aux nous puissions avoir du
lucratif mais bien évidemment il est
envisagé ça n'est pas possible soigner
des humains ou prendre en charge des
humains et que derrière vous ayez tab et
des sociétés cotées ont comme il ya un
illogisme ca total
il ya deux choses que vous dénoncez
c'est le fait de maximiser les profits
quitte à offrir des prestations
déplorable et aussi la maltraitance et
là on imagine qu'il ya des directions
des directives clairement de la
direction pour faire un maximum de
profits quand vous expliquer la
recrudescence de maltraitance est ce que
c'est parce que le personnel est à bout
peut-être à la personnalité beaucoup il
à bout on est mal prétend malgré soi
comme une personne pour un étage
genevois sa course mais bien faire vôtre
monsieur il explique il ya sept minutes
hall avait quelqu'un si quelqu'un et
c'est là que c'est la personne à l'étagé
malte le temps et qu'il faut la
retourner
des trois derniers rapports des députés
le marquent clairement ses marques et on
parle de maltraitance institutionnelle
d'ailleurs c'est d'ailleurs je
souhaiterais même qu on arrête de parler
du personnel c'est le système qui
aimerait tant faire arrêter de arrêtons
de dire que alors bien entendu on va on
va tomber sur des gens qui vont être pas
bien mais sur la très grande majorité
heureusement qu'on admire les lancers
boîte là qui se crèvent avec des cartes
nous faisons du travail de tous les
métiers puisque le batteur ans devant le
bâtiment c'est fou on a des femmes la
plupart du temps cette année un métier
hyper féminisé il ya quelque chose qui
va pas il ya quelque chose qui va pas 50
% des aides soignantes n'arrive pas à la
retraite elle sanctions il ya une
attitude soit ayant des problèmes elle
arrête avant et sont malades 50% des
actions n'arrive pas à la retraite
n'aurait pas présenté
en deux enfants à nourrir qui me disent
de toute façon je ne peux pas quitter ce
travail là sur la précarité la précarité
sociale de ces milieux là aussi que ces
grands employeurs avec leurs beaux
discours et tous à utiliser pressurise
le nombre de licenciements pour
inaptitude que j'ai fait vous rendez
compte que ça veut dire pour quelqu'un
est effectivement pas au niveau social
scolaire à 45 ballet se retrouver à la
rue parce que c'est à la rue rond on
vous pète et on vous jette sachant qu'en
plus elle n'avait pas le diplôme me
faisais faisant fonction passer
maintenant c'est autoriser une personne
qui n'a pas le diplôme a le droit de
faire fonction mais elle n'a pas eu peur
mais a pas cessé tous ces modules est
allé à l'école mais elle a appris sur le
tas et donc elle a le droit de faire des
actes médicaux en faisant fonction il
est payé comme une femme de ménage me
fait fonction est forcément se poser
problème le béatrice tout ce que vous
dites je l' ai vécu avec ma grand mère
qui est décédée en septembre elle était
dans un ehpad et on était très
malheureux ça fait culpabiliser les
familles aussi parce que on n'avait pas
d'autre choix n'avait pas d'autre
solution on se relayait on y allait
quasiment tous les jours et même en y
allant tous les jours il manquait
toujours quelque chose du papier et des
choses vraiment de la dignité de base
quoi de la dignité humaine de du papier
toilette des serviettes hygiéniques on
leur en acheter nous mêmes on lui rend
plomb lui acheter un petit frigo parce
qu'effectivement elle avait faim elle se
réveilla l'a perdue elle faisait à la
fin elle faisait peut-être 30 kg enfin
c'était vraiment incroyable et donc j'ai
vécu on appelait quant à elle appelé sur
le bouton rouge parce qu'elles ont ils
ont un bouton rouge personne ne venait
pendant des heures une fois ma mère a
fait le test en chambre elle a attendu
deux heures un après midi avant que
quelqu'un vienne
enfin tout ce que vous décrivez à tous
les niveaux en fait c'est la nourriture
mais effectivement il ya des infirmières
qui sont formidables qui portent à bout
de bras des personnes âgées qui se casse
le dow et c donc on peut pas les blâmer
ya juste pas assez de personnel et il ya
des listes d'attenté quand on râlait on
nous disait oh vous savez si vous n'êtes
pas contente vous pouvez en gros vous
pouvez dégager mais nous on n'avait pas
de solution parce que ma grand mère
était elle avait 101 ans quand elle est
décédée elle avait elle été trop
dépendante et on n'y avait pas d'autre
solution est donc mon pensez aussi aux
gens qui n'ont pas de visite parce que
nous on y allait tous les jours mais il
ya des gens qui n'ont aucune visite et
là c'est vraiment la catastrophe le coc
vide a aggravé les choses avec les
confinements isolement chambre les
masques il faut savoir que ces gens
finissent leur vie aujourd'hui en ne
voyant pas un visage humain il ne voit
que des masques c'est absolument
terrible voilà et je pourrais en parler
je vais pas en parler pendant des heures
mais je vais monopoly mais c'est
vraiment terrible il y a une
culpabilisation nous on s'en remet pas
parce qu'on n'avait pas de pardon on
n'avait pas le choix on ne savait pas
quoi faire d'autre à la du ventes sont à
part son petit appartement ma grand-mère
pour payer le lait et pourtant c'est
effectivement il ya une grosse partie
qui est remboursé par là par la sécurité
sociale mais ça ne devrait pas tout et
on faisait tout ce qu'on pouvait en lui
amener chaque jour des pâtisseries des
choses et tout aimé voilà et de se vouer
le pire je vais vous dire le pire c'est
qu'il ya beaucoup de ces personnes
de ses résidents qui ont encore leur
leur tête et qui se voit être là bas et
qui comprennent tous qu'ils voient qu'on
a deux minutes pour les laver qui se
sentent brutalisé dans leur intimité
elles sont tout nus dans des douches
debout et tout c'est horrible et c'est
ça le pire je crois que c'est c'est la
partie psychologique à la limite parce
que les gens savent que ces voilà c'est
comme ça qu'ils vont finir leur vie et
c'est vraiment terrible quoi il avait
souligné souligné de confinement dans
dans les ehpad au moment du coc vide un
exemple frappant un copain à moi sa
maman est en ehpad elle a 90 ans il peut
pas aller la voir il sait qu'à va mal il
sait qu'elle est tombée il a pas de
nouvelles il reçoit un coup tu es folle
un matin à 8 heures les pompes funèbres
de châtillon 92 gestion pour fergie à
monsieur x on est en train de mettre ce
moment dans la housse dans la housse
vous pourrez venir la voir au
crématorium mais par contre on porte en
ouvrir le cercueil il appelle la
direction le directeur n'était pas là il
a eu les condoléances ces établissements
korian ses sorties dans la presse il a
eu ses condoléances au directeur plus
d'une semaine après incroyable il a même
pas été prévenus par l'institution que
sa maman était décédé sur les pompes
funèbres qui l'ont appelée à la scandale
ça quand même elle est où l'humanité la
c1